thank you very much for having me um so today
we're going to be talking about teaching our
online with RStudio cloud and the link
to the slides is here on the first slide
and you'll be able to see it on the footer of
most of the slides that i'll be going through
um that goes to the rendered slides and i'm not
going to be showing much code today or any at
all actually we're going to be talking about
how to set up RStudio cloud for your teaching
but if you're interested in the source files
i'd be happy to provide a link to that as well
so let's get started the first question i'd like
to answer is why might you be interested in using
rstudio in the cloud there are a few reasons um
first one is how do your students get started when
they're starting to learn r so here is one recipe
you can get your students to install r RStudio
install a bunch of packages that you're going to
use for that lesson or for the entire duration
of your course load the packages if you're using
version control they need to also make sure git is
installed and this list could keep going if you're
teaching anything beyond an introductory course
this produces every single bullet point here
produces a friction point especially if you're
working with an audience that is new to r on
the other hand here's another alternative go
to your browser go to this link and log in and
the environment is already set up for you so
this is much less friction to begin with another
reason though is maybe you used to be teaching
in a setup like this and now your students are in
their own bedrooms and uh signing on individually
so you no longer have neither do you have control
over what's on their computer necessarily because
it's not a computer lab that maybe you've
worked with your university it to set up
but also you don't get to look over their
shoulder anymore maybe you're teaching
remotely at this point um and so we're going to
be touching on a few things that RStudio cloud
makes easier as you're teaching remotely as well
all right so how do we get RStudio in the cloud
we have a couple options again one option is an
option that RStudio has been providing pretty much
forever i would say is RStudio server pro so what
is RStudio server pro this is a piece of software
that if you have these following things you
can get running with you either yourself as the
instructor needs this admin experience or support
from your it you also need either hardware to
install the software on or a local virtual machine
setup or some sort of cloud computing credit and
each one of these is basically cost points as
you can imagine both the support and also the
hardware or wherever you're going to be doing your
compute in addition to that you yourself probably
have some RStudio experience if you have all
of these this might be the right option for you
however if you're having to shift your teaching
mid-semester quickly without much notice even if
you have much of these uh happening this may not
necessarily be the right time to be undertaking
something that takes multiple steps to set up but
i wanted to leave this here on this slide and also
have a link to the rcd academic pricing
which basically says that if you are using
the software for teaching purposes you can
freely license it the whole package itself
doesn't end up being free somebody's paying for
the it support time somebody's paying for compute
but ultimately the software itself is free and you
can get your students on to these this machine and
the r studio instances and they're ready to keep
going um just like i we said in the first slide
alternatively if you're using RStudio cloud really
the only thing you need is RStudio experience so
you don't need this as admin experience rit
support and you don't actually need anything
related to compute either so let's talk a little
bit about RStudio cloud so we're not going to
be talking about the other option but we are
going to be talking about RStudio cloud today
RStudio cloud was created to make it easy for
professionals hobbyists trainers teachers and
students to do share teach and learn data science
using r this is the mission of RStudio cloud and
this is basically the sentence you're going to
find when you go to RStudio.cloud um what does
RStudio cloud look like if this is what the r
studio id looks like on your local machine this
is what RStudio cloud looks like as you can see it
looks exactly the same and that is important if we
are using this to get your students started
because you don't want to be teaching them
in an environment where that experience is not
going to just carry over to the local instance
experience the only difference is they're running
it in the browser so it comes with a url to go to
why might you want why might you want to use
RStudio cloud over other options other ways
of getting RStudio in your web browser like
RStudio server pro first of all it does not
require it support which means that you don't
need to convince somebody else for their time
to help you with it get works out of the box which
is i think a huge advantage if you're teaching
with version control oftentimes what i hear is
that if folks are teaching with version control
they might be doing it not necessarily in an intro
course but in a more advanced course where they
feel like students should be able to go through
the installation step okay that might very well be
true installing rnr studio is not too cumbersome
to be perfectly honest but getting git to work
on every single one of your students machines
in a local install is not necessarily trivial
you can also knit to pdf and knit to word which
means that tech is installed and word is installed
so if these are output options you use with our
markdown um you already have those uh readily set
up for yourself as well but additional to this
it has a bunch of features that are designed
specifically for instructors for example your
classes can be organized in workspaces which
means that if you're running many classes
it becomes a lot easier to manage them
members can be assigned different roles so
you can have different permission levels for
instructors tas and students your projects can
be public or private and you get to control that
for your students your projects can be made
into assignments which makes it a lot easier
for your students to get started your students
can make copies of projects so you can basically
set up projects up to a certain point and ask your
students to pick things up from that point onwards
i think one of the most attractive features is
that you as the instructor can peek into your
students project so we can actually recreate that
experience of looking over your student's shoulder
even though you're not in the same room with
them and finally a base project template can
ensure that you have the same packages in each new
project created in the workspace so you no longer
should have a situation where you write some code
and your student says they run the exact same code
but they're getting something different from you
or a classmate when you get to RStudio cloud you
can get started just like this and on the login
window you can either create an account or sign
up with something like google or github or if
you have a shiny apps at io account that will
also work as well and you'll end into a blank
slate like this so there are two things that
you can see here there is something called your
workspace and i usually like to think about your
workspace in the center as the sandbox i play in
i rarely put teaching stuff there but instead i
use separate workspaces for each one of my
classrooms we will go through each one of
these options but generally as an instructor
i like keeping my individual workspace as my
sandbox for trying things out or one-off sharing
and the individual workspaces for a classroom
so workspaces when you create an account on
RStudio cloud you get this workspace of your own
you can add a new workspace and control its
permissions that's why i think it's attractive
option for setting up a class and projects
in either workspace either the ones that you
create specifically for a class or your own can
be public or private so you can use it as your own
or you can use it to share it with people what is
the project in our studio cloud well a new project
in our studio cloud is basically a new project in
the r studio ide um i've met many people who have
been using rstudio for years and years but
don't necessarily use the project features
i'm not necessarily going to be taking a whole lot
of time to describe why that's beneficial but even
if you are using our studio your local install i
strongly strongly recommend that you use projects
if you get nothing out of this webinar but that
tip i think that will still be worth your hour
trust me you won't regret it and if you do want to
learn more about why it is a good idea to be using
our studio projects even in the local ide i
have a link to the relevant section and the
r for data science book in the slides similarly
you can create projects from git a git repository
so a new project from a git repository in our
studio cloud is the same thing as creating a
new project from git in the rstudio ide both of
these actions clone a git repository so you have
two ways of initiating a project a blank slate
or something that comes from a git repository
when you're so we talked about these two options
you have your own workspace or you can create
classes these are your two options for sharing
projects with students we're going to start with
the simpler approach although i will mention why
i would recommend this slightly more complicated
approach option two but option one is you create a
single project and you share it with your students
this is how easy it is it actually the
instructions fit into a tweet so that's
less than 280 characters go to RStudio.cloud
login create a new project install any packages
add any scripts or markdown documents that
you want to share with your students change
the access level to be available to everyone
copy the url and share it with your students
so going forward you're going to see these
two icons on my slides one of them is for
the teacher and the other one is for the student
so i'll be walking you through some views of what
our studio cloud looks like um and we're going to
be using these in the bottom right corner of the
slides to see are we looking at the teacher
view or are we looking at the student view
let's start with creating a new single project
um so i'm going and creating a new project once
the project is deployed what i can do to start it
for uh to get it ready for my students is i might
for example choose to install some packages that
i'm going to be using in whatever class example
or for the workshop that i am teaching um any
of the packages that you install will then be
uh available for your students as well something
i really like to do is just create an our markdown
document quickly um that will actually prompt the
rcdo instance to install any necessary packages
as well i usually teach with our markdown
documents so i usually place a template our
markdown document to get students started with
so if you knit this the file is going to get
saved um which means that when your students may
get their own copy of the project they're going to
be able to see that file as well you might want to
rename the project itself so that when you share
it students know uh get inherit that name as well
and ultimately uh you want to share that url with
your students but by default your projects are
available only to you so first you need to change
the access level clicking on the gear icon and
then you can simply send that url to your students
now let's look at the student
view as to how this looks
the student has received that url from
their instructor they place it into their um
browser they log on and what they're seeing is
that same project you can see with the same name
called workshop materials but one thing that
is different is that it says temporary project
on top so your students need to remember to save a
permanent copy and what is happening at this point
is a copy of the project is made for them to
further iterate on if they forget to do that they
lose their changes but you can see that they're
able to get they got the same document that you
had created and in fact if we try to just load
the tidy burst package which we had previously
installed on the instructor side it loads meaning
that the install has actually carried through
so pros and cons of sharing a signal project like
this what's good about it is that students land
directly in a project upon login which means they
get they get the url from you and what they see is
RStudio and RStudio ide and they can get started
it works well for workshops where all the work
that will be done completed is in a single project
um but i don't think it works really well where
you have where you're going to have a much longer
running class and you're going to have a lot of
work that you're going to be doing throughout
the class or if you want to track students in
some way it is also great for sharing code in
general so outside of a teaching setting if you
want to do it for collaboration or to create
a replex one of the things i love using this
feature for is represses for shiny apps that tend
to be sometimes long um i have lots of code so you
can basically put it in an rcdo cloud instance and
share it with somebody else for them to try it out
the not so good side is that remember that
red reminder on top that's a temporary project
students need to remember to make a copy of the
project and yes it's red and yes it's blinking
but people forget and when i say students need
to remember really what i mean is you as the
instructor need to remind them um so that places
additional burden on you as well because if they
don't and they work on it and then they close out
of their browser when they come back they're not
going to be able to see their work um another
thing that's not so good is that you can't keep
track of which students started their assignments
so they you share the url with them and then it
just goes out into the ether you don't have a way
of seeing if a student has derived a project from
yours and i'll be able to see that show you the
flip side of this when you use the other paradigm
additionally if you are concerned about students
sharing work this is not a great option because
now that a student owns that project when they
make a copy of a non-temporary copy for themselves
they now control the permissions of that project
which means they can simply share it with another
friend and if this is an assignment where you
don't want students sharing code now you've made
it additionally easy for them to do so obviously
um you controlling permissions of a project does
not necessarily mean your students aren't going
to cheat if that's what they really want to do
but i think as instructors uh it is important
for us if we do want to follow certain rules
about sharing work that we don't use a platform
that makes it too easy for students to cheat
um on a remote teaching note i think
one of the things that makes it
hardest for sharing a single project is that
you can't easily peek into student projects
they would need to explicitly share the project
with you i'm not sure why my bullet point is cut
off here but basically they need to set the access
level to be available to everybody else and then
send the url to you as opposed to you being able
to track it much more easily so i think that this
idea of using our studio cloud as a way of peeking
over your students shoulder to help them with
any troubles that they're having does not really
apply when you share a single project with them
the other option is to create a workspace and
get your students into that workspace so when
i think about creating a workspace i think about
i'm building my classroom and the people who are
in uh invited in here are the people who are um in
my class either my students or my helpers or tas
so how do we go about creating a workspace
and then sharing it with our students so as
an instructor i click on new space on the sidebar
give a name for my new space and also give it a
description this is the name and the description
your students will encounter when you ultimately
invite them to this workspace i create the
workspace and then i'm going to do a bunch
of prep before i actually invite my students in
so that's how easy it is to create the workspace
um the next step is thinking about who is going
to be in the workspace so how do i get students
into a class workspace there's a tab called
members so if i click on that uh you can see that
currently i myself is the only person in
this workspace and my role is noted as admin
and on the right hand side you can see a bunch of
options so let's drill down into those the first
thing that you might want to think about is how
are you going to invite students into your class
unfortunately there isn't just yet um an
easy way to like upload a roster for example
of student emails so what my recommendation
would be is instead of choosing invitation
require where you would have to actually uh
individually invite each one of your students
especially if you're teaching a larger class
i would recommend setting the access option to
shared um but do so for a short period of time and
share this link with your students and you want
to enroll them as contributors and i will talk
about what the other access levels are in a second
when i say share this link with your students
though i might recommend if you are worried
about random strangers getting into your workspace
that that sharing is not necessarily done in
a um public way so if you keep a public course
website for example instead of pasting it there
use for example your course management
software or a roster that you have to
email the link to your students if you
don't care about who gets in this workspace
at that point then it doesn't really matter how
you share it so after initial round of enrollment
uh this could be a drop or this could be a couple
days if you're having to shift gears mid semester
switch this over to this access level over
to invitation required and then going forward
you can use invitations for any other people you
need to add oftentimes i might have like another
colleague who wants to see how i'm running things
so i might add them as visitors to my workspace
so the different permission levels we saw
that my name was listed as admin i am the
owner um and i think that role admin really
translates to instructor in a teaching setting
i can do everything i can manage users
view edit and manage all projects
in fact nuke the workspace if i want to another
level is moderator which in an instructor in an
instructional sense would uh maybe correspond
to a ta these uh the moderators can view edit
and manage all projects but they don't really
get to manage users contributors are what i
would say students they can create edit and
manage only their own projects and a viewer
um usually i use it in a course setting as an
auditor or a visitor or colleague who might want
to see how things are working they can only
view projects that are shared with everyone
so under the members that same tab um we also
saw these permission levels and i would recommend
unchecking all of these so what are they
saying contributors can see the members list
this is basically saying should your students be
able to see each other's names if you think about
just your students being able to see each
other's names maybe that's not a big deal
but um if you are going to potentially open this
course up to the public you might have concerns
about your students names being publicly
available so i tend to like to uncheck that box
um contributors can make their projects visible to
all members if this is for a course that is graded
where you are expecting that students not share
code with each other let's not make it easier for
them to do so so you can uncheck that box as well
um contributors can change project resources so
you can change how much memory is allocated
to certain projects um this might be something
you might want to check or you might want to
uncheck i would say especially if you're teaching
introductory students chances are this is not
going to be a concept they're super comfortable
with anyway so you can uncheck that you can always
set that level for them yours yourself later on
and ultimately should viewers like auditors be
able to see the members list and i usually uncheck
that too the moral of the story here is that you
should think carefully before checking these boxes
and if you're not sure leave them unchecked
when you create a new workspace you by default
can get uh 10 people in there including
yourself a lot of us teach courses that
have more than 10 students in it so we have this
limit there in order to keep track of usage levels
so you can actually request more members on that
members tab um and i would recommend doing so as
soon as you set this up what this means is that if
you're setting this up today and wanting to teach
it tomorrow morning first thing that might be a
little tough because a human actually needs to
approve this so put in your request as quickly as
possible and tell us a bit about what you're using
this space for we're not denying any requests
at this point this is more for tracking of what
people are using RStudio cloud for so that we can
try to anticipate what the demand levels might be
another very attractive feature of RStudio cloud
if you're using workspaces is this idea of a base
project so what do i mean by a base project
in this base project you can the packages you
want installed on students projects live there
um text documents that you want to appear on
all student projects also live there i usually
use this for something like a code of conduct for
example or if you have specific instructions
that um that are the same from assignment
to assignments you can put in things like
how do you turn in your work there as well
um any the base project applies to all projects
created after the base project has been specified
it does not apply retroactively and that should be
an attractive feature once people create a project
in the class the setting of the settings of that
project shouldn't change if you later decide to
change how your base project looks i think most
importantly the base project can be updated
as many times as you like throughout the course
without having to convince any it people so there
might be a new version of a package that you want
your students to learn about and you can choose
to install that package to your base project
at 2am the night before you teach and tomorrow
morning when they get in and start working
on an assignment it'll be available to them
how does it work to create a base project um
there are a few steps for it you start by creating
just like any old project in this base project
you're going to want to install any packages
that you may want to have i like renaming the
project right away as base project you really
can use any name you want it just needs to
be identifiable um so that you can choose
it from a list later as i said before i always
like creating in our markdown document because
that list of packages i forget what they are
like all the list of packages you need to get
our markdown up and running at least RStudio does
it automatically for me so even though i'm not
putting in our markdown document here i go through
the motions of doing so i like adding a plain
text file that is basically a code of conduct so i
would add some verbiage to that but to keep things
simple i'll leave it just with a heading for
now this means this file is going to be carried
copied over to every single project created in
this workspace um and then i'm going to want to
make choose this to be my base project but i'm
showing you something here that i almost do every
single time which is that before you can make
a project your base project you need to change
its permissions to be available to everyone
okay so we want to change the permissions to
be available to everyone then we click on the
gear icon and select the base project by name
and then if at a later point you want to edit it
you can actually do so so say tomorrow you decide
to teach a topic that uses a package that you
haven't used before you can actually go ahead and
add that package to your base project and
you can see that once a project has been
set as a base project it disappears from the
project list so now i'm creating a regular
project in my class let's say this is the homework
one assignment that i'm creating for my students
i can create a template document
for them to start working on
and you will see that as i'm creating this
document rstudio does not prompt me to
install the packages that are required for our
markdown because those already got carried over
from my base project if i if this is the homework
assignment i want to give i'm going to make it
available to everyone and i'm going to check
the box next to make this assignment make this
project an assignment now that i have set up a
base project and the first homework assignment
in my class it is time for me to invite my
students i go to the members tab of my workspace
um i click choose shared i say that initial row
for my students should be contributors and i copy
the sharing link it's going to end up being an
awfully long link you might want to use a link
shortener or something before you email it to your
students it doesn't really matter and then your
student now receives that email from you with the
link to the workspace so how do things look like
for your student they go to that link and this
is where they land they need to log in and they
can use if they have an existing google account
log in it says do you want to join the space yes
and they land here with your message about this
is what this workspace is for and if they get
to the projects they can see their homework one
assignment and start it so you can see that the
our markdown file you set up for them is there
the document knits without prompting students
to install any packages the code of conduct
from the base project is also there as well
one other thing i will mention is git integration
i said that git works out of the box for studio
cloud this is only relevant if you're teaching
with git and github i mean in a teaching context
if it's only relevant if you're teaching version
control as well um i think the really really
attractive thing is that your base project
templates can be used which means that when
students go and clone a new project from git they
will get any plain text files that live in that
git repository but the rstudio cloud project that
they initiate will also have the right packages
installed so they get the text files that are
going to be version tracked um from git but they
land them in an r studio environment that has
the right packages with the right versions and
everything you have set up for them installed on
the other side a little bit disappointing side at
least for now if you're teaching with git you need
to introduce yourself to get once per each project
that usually translates to for each assignment
that you assign to your students for example
which means that at the beginning of each of
your assignments you're probably going to want
to include uh some instructions like one of the
following if you're happy with your students
using the terminal remember that the rstudio
ide has a terminal window and they can use
commands like git config username and git
config user email and run those in the terminal
personally for teaching introductory courses
i try to not land my students in the terminal
as much as possible so i like the function called
use git config from uh the use this package which
basically um has runs the same thing that that it
amounts to the same thing as running the commands
in the terminal except they're doing things in our
studio so things feel a little bit more familiar
now important thing here is that if you're going
to be asking students to use to use this command
you want to make sure that you install the
use this package in your base package as well
so they're not um they're not going to have
to install it themselves so your instructions
work out of the box so pros and cons of sharing a
workspace in this manner on the good side you get
these various permission levels which i think is
really attractive especially if you work with tas
um the base projects with the desired packages
installed is another attractive feature
the assignment feature removes the
need to remind students to make a
copy of the project before they start work so
they no longer get that pesky temporary project
blinking light instead as they click start for
assignments as they click start on an assignment
RStudio cloud automatically makes that copy for
them and i think most most importantly especially
for remote teaching this ability to peek
in the student projects is very attractive
on the not so good side students land in the
workspace and they may need some instructions to
figure out what they need to do next
because when they land in the uh workspace
remember they see your workspace name and your
instructions so you might want to put in your
instruct or your welcome message something like
now click on projects to find out your assignments
um the get config step that we just talked about
for each project can get tedious and i think most
importantly it doesn't reflect realistic practice
if you're running things locally that config step
is something you would probably do globally just
once on your computer um i do hope that that's
something um that will change soon and uh once uh
we have a different way of figuring out how files
are shared at the system level for each account um
as i mentioned for remote teaching you now you can
easily peek into your student project so here is
a workshop that i taught um remotely and i have
projects for each one of the modules in the
workshop and for i usually like this view
in my workspaces where you can see on the right
hand side for list projects i only click on yours
which means mine which means i don't have to
see all the copies that my students have made
because if you have hundreds of students that
list is going to get very long but it gives
me this really nicely organized view of the
modules or assignments i've given my students
and i can click on those links that says view
drive projects and i didn't want to show you
the next step because it would have student
names in there but then you would be able to
see the projects of every single one of your
students who have made a copy and then click
on it and actually go into their project so you
can see their code exactly where they left it
which is great for helping them obviously i
think initially you probably want to get them
to describe to you what the issue is but things
can get a little bit frustrating especially
if you can't see their screen so this
is an opportunity to actually peek in
and you can also see how many students or which
students actually started their work if that's
something you want to track at certain points of
an assignment a few common pitfalls using either
paradigm sharing projects or sharing a workspace
it's important to remember that when a student
makes a copy of your project or when they start
an assignment our studio cloud is making a literal
copy of that project at that time point so changes
you make after a student launches a project
under either model won't propagate to their
project this is not like collaborative editing
of google docs it is more like you distributing
handing out paper to your students and then if you
make changes to your own copy that's
not going to propagate to theirs
what does this mean um until you're ready to share
an assignment with your students i would recommend
keeping the access level to be available only to
you which is the default anyway so you could be
working on your what your next week's homework
is going to look like um and your students
don't need to see that work until you're ready to
actually make that project available to everyone
another common pitfall that i see is that packages
in the base project will be installed for everyone
but they will not be loaded so if you need
students to run code in the console that
requires a package your instructions should
remind them to load the package first so run
something like a library command they never should
need to run install packages unless that's part
of your learning objective of course but they
do need to run the library command and also if
using in our markdown document that you're giving
them as a template you might have a chunk on top
that loads the packages that you want um how do we
get fee if you have any feedback or questions or
our studio cloud isn't working and you need some
troubleshooting uh the first thing you can do is
you'll see on the left hand side um on the menu at
the bottom you'll see a link to system status will
which will take you to status.rtstudio.com
and there you can see all the hosted services
that our studio runs one of which is our studio
cloud but also things like shiny apps at i o
as well and if things seem normal there um then i
would recommend and but you are having difficulty
with something then i would recommend reporting
it because you might be the first person who is
actually seeing the issue you might also see that
it might be going uh that rcd cloud might be under
active maintenance or that there is an issue
that's reported and there's certain levels in
the uh team that works the engineering team that
works on our studio cloud if there is actually an
outage issue we'll provide details there so
that's really the first place to check to see
what's up with our studio cloud today
other options if you're having any sort of
either questions about how to do something on
our studio cloud or want to report at the issue
you can post on our studio community um but you
can also email support rstudio.cloud i think the
third option might be especially useful if you are
an instructor and you have to share something like
a link to a student project so that if there's
an issue with this particular student's work
that the student can't get into it that may not
be something you may want to share publicly on
our studio community so you're welcome to
email support at our studio cloud with that
um a couple of things that are on
the horizon for our studio cloud
uh we are working towards providing institution
accounts so this will be especially useful if you
are a person who is maybe a course organizer for
a course that runs with multiple sections and you
want to be able to manage them in a centralized
fashion you should be able to do that this is
coming down the pipeline soon another thing is
a dashboard for student usage and engagement
metrics so you can see on a monthly basis maybe
how many members you have how many active projects
what the compute units are and you'll be
able to drill down into these more as well
um and we are also we have a package actually
called r rs cloud that is uh for managing RStudio
cloud spaces with r it currently um requires
an api key which any instructor can request
currently you need to do that via email to
support at RStudio.cloud but soon you'll
be able to do so in the ui as well uh some of the
attractive features of this package is that it has
um functions for inviting your students to your
workspace and stuff like that so you can basically
get to automate some of those steps um instead of
having to click around in the r studio cloud ui
a few parting remarks i'll start with some tips
so first of all each project is allocated one
gig of ram which means that you really should
test things out before assignments involving
especially large data sets it's important that
you give this a try and one of the things where
you may not be able to try is if you have a
project that is involving um students to go
get their own data sets um then you kind of can't
necessarily foresee what whether or not the memory
will be sufficient remember that you can increase
the memory allocation of a project if you need
but it's important to test things out so you
don't run into kind of surprising roadblocks
in the middle of teaching another really
important thing is that what your students see
is not always what you see earlier on in
the slides i had the little icons for the
teacher view and the student view and we could
see that those look a little bit different
my strong recommendation for you would be to
create a secondary account with another throwaway
email address you have and add that person that
account as a student at the contributor level
i would recommend logging on from that account
from something like an incognito window
so that you can test to see what your
students will see before they actually see it
more tips um i think brief screencasts for
getting students oriented with a platform
this is especially true if you're remote
teaching and you don't if you don't have a
synchronous component to your teaching or
you won't be able to you know show things
on the board like you might uh when you're
teaching in person uh i think is really useful
the screencasts that i showed um during this
webinar are included in this youtube playlist
if you would like to borrow some of them many of
them are geared towards instructors but a couple
of them were from the student view so you're
welcome to use those if you would like to do so
another thing that i see very regularly
is that this is what the r studio cloud
window looks like when you first start
and many of our students work on not huge
screens but something like a 13-inch
laptop or a chromebook that's even smaller
and so the real estate is really limited and you
have this sidebar on the left hand side and a lot
of students forget to x out of that to close it
and they lose a valuable real estate so i would
recommend reminding your students that they can
click on that x next to the rstudio cloud logo and
the sidebar will go away that will extend their r
studio ide screen so they have a little bit more
room to play with um finally read the rstudio
cloud guide um inevitably this webinar is going
to get a little bit out of date as our studio
cloud evolves but the rcdo cloud guide um that
is linked from the sidebar as well is going to
be the most up-to-date information on how our
studio cloud works because the engineering team
adds to that um as they build more features out
on the rstudio cloud website on the sidebar you'll
also see a link to the primers these are learn our
tutorials that the RStudio education team has put
together these are free um to use and they are
basically a companion to the r for data science
book by garrett broliman and hadley wickham
so if there are certain things that
you want to offload your teaching to
to uh tutorials others have prepared before you
might be able to see valuable materials here
um they don't actually use RStudio cloud right now
they're just learn our tutorials that are hosted
on shiny apps that i o but they're easily
accessible from the rstudio cloud screen
and finally um RStudio cloud is in
beta so um it continues to evolve
and we are you know working on making sure that
it's really reliable and available um if you have
any questions the place to go is RStudio community
and for now RStudio cloud is currently free to
use and as we learn what it costs to operate uh
the service and how it's used by the community
there will be a paid plan available for it as
well but for the time being it's free to use um
so you can go ahead and start set up
your clouds there tomorrow if you want
thank you very much for listening in and
i'd be happy to answer any questions now
so one of the questions says by any chance uh
does RStudio cloud integrate well with moodle
currently there is no specific learning
management system integration with RStudio cloud
but this is certainly um in the pathway for
development because we know that this is something
instructors are going to want um so what does this
mean that means that currently there is not a way
for you to get all your students that might be
on moodle or any other learning system management
system use with your university directly into an
rstudio cloud workspace but as i said as long as
you're able to reach out to them you can share
the workspace link with them obviously it's a
manual step but that's how you can get them in
the next thing probably is submission of work
if you are using a learning management system it
is very likely that you will ultimately want your
students to submit their work there um so what
i would recommend doing is once student do their
students do their work on our studio cloud they
can actually export out any files using the files
pane in the r studio ide check the boxes for any
files they want to submit click on more and then
export that will create a zipped folder that they
can upload to their learning management system
when it comes to actually grading their work
you may want to choose with what they submitted
there or you may want to simply go into their
projects on our cdo cloud that's entirely up
to you but if you want an official record of
submission that's what i would recommend doing
let's see could we download the
slides yes you can actually go to the
link and get the slides while they're made
with sure engine so they are um html slides
can the student also have the workspace open when
me instructor peeks into their workspace okay so
that's a really good question and i will start by
um some terminology there so the workspace is your
classroom and what your student is working on is
a project and it's a project that you're peeking
into so can you be peeking into that project
while the student also has the project open
um it actually does kick them out it doesn't
necessarily crash their session per se but it
kicks them out briefly and so let me tell you
how i like using this usually i don't just peek
into student projects without um us getting to a
point in the conversation where i feel like that's
going to be needed i try to encourage students
on a discussion forum that we use for course q a
to try to describe the problem that they have
as well as possible but if it comes to the point
where i feel like i need to look in i tell them
that i'm about to go into your workspace you may
want to save your files not that not them not
saving the files will be an issue but students
get worried if they get kicked out with unsaved
files so i remind them to do so and then peek
into their workspace and then let them know again
when i get out of there on the online discussion
forum or wherever we're conversing um that this
is what i'm doing another way i've used this
is actually um on a synchronous call something
like a zoom call for example i tell the student
okay this is i'm going to go into that it's going
to kick you out but they can actually watch me
work in their project and see what changes i've
made to debug the issue that they were having
what's the process for sharing data files just
load them into the workspace um so the process
for sharing data files is you load them into the
project you create a new project that is going to
be an exercise or an assignment your students
are working on and using the files pane in the
rstudio ide you can upload any files directly into
there a file size constraint so i think the issue
more so than file size constraints is the memory
um so you may want to think about not just your
data file size but what you're going to be do with
to be doing with it if you are simply running you
know depart commands a lot large data file is
not going to be an issue but if you're going
to be running bootstrap like bootstrap sampling
on that uh on a large data frame with many rows
and doing so over tens of thousands of times then
that might actually be an issue and that's why i
mentioned you may want to test out what it is
that you want to do in terms of the assignment
how do you load a data set or existing files
into the cloud so i think this is that same
question so on the files pane um there is a
button that says upload and that's how you do that
um can we run code chunks in python or c um the
answer should be yes it's running the r studio
ide so yes you can run python chunks i'm fairly
certain this is true now i have to test that out
um you said that sharing a project with students
there are two main ways in the first way they have
to make a copy of the project in order to not
to lose the changes can you show how to do this
so let's go back uh real quick so this is the
student view of the project so let's go to the
very beginning of this your student comes to the
project that you shared with them um they log on
and i'm going to pause the screen when i need
to in a second so over here they can see that
the project is temporary and this is blinking and
next to it they can see a button that says save a
permanent copy when they click on save a permanent
copy that blinking temporary project is going to
go away and what that does at that instance is
it makes a copy of that project that places them
into their own like personal workspace that i call
the sandbox at the beginning of the presentation
another question i had a problem with
RStudio connect RStudio cloud to connect
it to relational databases um okay i i
let's leave that question out to the um
RStudio community discussion thread that
we'll have available for this because i don't
know off the top of my head as i haven't
tried this myself before in my teaching
so i'm going to hold off on answering the question
about using RStudio cloud and relational databases
another question is i assume the students can
download files locally as typically they will
need to submit assignments in the lms that's
absolutely correct they can download the files
using the files pane check the boxes next to the
files that they want to download click on more
and then export which will export them out as a
zip file which i find is an attractive feature
because then they simply need to upload that
zip file onto your learning management system
some of the learning management systems i've
worked with in the past sometimes don't like
certain extensions like html or our markdown
they may not know what it is but usually are
okay with zip folders so it doesn't matter how you
have them what you have them knit their files to
usually a zipped file upload is
something that an lms accepts
do i need a separate space for each group of
students if i have more than one so i think this
depends on what you mean by group if the students
are all exposed to the same material in the class
and the same assignments at that point you should
not need separate spaces even if they're saying
different workshop groups or something however
if you have more than one classes that you're
teaching so these are going to be separate content
for each of the classes separate assignments
you probably don't want to confuse the students
with assignments for another class in which case
you would need to have separate workspaces is it
possible to correct homeworks automatically or do
we need to visualize students answers there is no
built-in auto grading that is built into RStudio
cloud if you are interested in doing auto grading
with work with r i think the most promising thing
and you need this student code to be run i suppose
uh the most promising thing i can think of is if
you teach with version control you can have your
students push their work to a github repository
and you could run continuous integration tools
like github actions on it to provide um instant
feedback to the students or to do auto grading
this is not necessarily a fully solved problem
just yet but that seems to be the most um kind
of doable option for going forward on that uh
but in terms of grading student work on RStudio
cloud your option is to go into their project and
start working through it or you have them submit
the output file through some other means and then
you simply evaluate the output file it depends
on what it is that you are evaluating them on
it seems like we do not need to request anything
if you're if our group is under 25 students
um if your group is under 10 students you do not
need to request anything otherwise by default in a
workspace you can only have up to 10 students or i
guess 9 students because one of the seats is taken
by you um another question is from uh somebody
who's teaching intro to deep learning course
and it looks like it could solve a
lot of issues if we have um six years
to use RStudio cloud but they will probably need
substantial computation time is there anything i
should take into account specifically on the
computation side of things in RStudio cloud
so i think this is where we come to the memory
conversation here so you are probably going to
need to request higher memory limits and that's
something that what i would recommend that you do
is create a workspace put some of your materials
in a project within that workspace try running
through it and see what's choking and if
it is the case that the memory allocated by
default the one gig is not sufficient then
i would reach out to support rstudio.cloud
to describe your use case um i know that we
have so that would require an increased memory
limit so that's something that you're going to
need to request ahead of time thank you so much